hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter 11 of thomas hobbes leviathan is
entitled of the difference
of manners and hobbs specifies
at the very beginning by manners i mean
not hear
decency of behavior as you know for
example how
one person should salute another or
greet another
how a person should wash their mouth or
pick their teeth
before company and such other points of
what he calls the small
morals or what we nowadays call
etiquette right
instead he says manners can be
understood as signifying you know the
fundamental motivations and dynamics
that that
we can call moral psychology he doesn't
use that
term but that's often what we we call it
now
and he tells us that what he's really
concerned with are the
qualities of mankind or humanity
that concern their living together in
peace
and unity so you know this is the
central goal of
leviathan as a whole how can we
as human beings enjoy a good life
whatever the good life is going to be
and we're going to talk about that in
just a moment
it's definitely going to depend on
maintaining what he calls the state of
peace
as opposed to being in a condition of
war
or you know the chance of being at war
in conflict with other people a state of
war
of all against all potential he wants to
avoid that so
by understanding human psychology
and the way our motivations work we
could better understand
how to bring about a condition in which
we're not going to be at each other's
throats so
hobbes tells us and this is where we get
to a very distinctive
aspect of his ethics and his moral
psychology
there is no sum bonum there is no fenus
ultimos now what does that mean so
sum bonum is the supreme good the thing
that
you know everything else should be in
relation to if we
pass it up we screwed up our life uh
everything else should be
oriented towards achieving that that
supreme good or
final end our our most fundamental
goal and hobbes is differing from
so many other authors in
moral psychology and in ethics
of his time and before his time in
saying listen there isn't any such thing
like aristotle said happiness which
would consist of virtuous activity
with a certain amount of wealth and
relationships the stoics
said just virtue by itself we could
conceive of other
final ends as well and hobbes is saying
listen you can talk about that if you
want but there isn't really
any such thing that that term
corresponds to
he says you know as they're spoken of in
the books of the old moral philosophers
and he says no nor can a and a man
anymore live whose desires are at an end
than he whose senses and imagination are
at an end
felicity happiness is another term for
that is
a continual progress of the desire
from one object to another the attaining
of the former being still
but the the way to the latter and the
cause
of this is the object of a person's
desire is not to enjoy once only and for
one instant of time but to assure
forever
the way of their future desire so hobbes
is saying
whatever you get you're not going to
remain content with it you're going to
want more could be more of that thing or
it could be
other things he's got some nice examples
a little bit
later on he says
here we go kings whose power is greatest
turn their endeavors to the assuring it
at home
by laws or abroad by wars and
when that is done there succeeded a new
desire
in some fame from new conquest and
others ease and central pleasure
in others admiration or being flattered
for excellence in some other art
or some other ability of the mind so
hobbes is saying listen whatever you
set on and tell yourself is the the goal
the thing that you want
it ain't it's not that you will reach it
and then you're gonna want more you're
gonna want something else and that's
normal that's the way human beings
are so he says in the first place i put
for a general inclination of all mankind
a perpetual and restless desire of power
after power that sees only in
death now power is the ability to attain
apparent goods as he said in the
previous chapter so
we're seeking power after power after
power because we're seeking these things
that will
please us or we're trying to avoid
things that will displease us
and it ceases only when we die now
you could say okay well he's got a
general idea there
so he's still talking about something
that's a
human dynamic why are we so different on
so many matters he says well there's
differences between people
and those differences stem from
differences
in their passions or what we would call
the emotional
or affective structure of of their mind
right and differences in their degrees
or objects of knowledge if you don't
know something if you're ignorant about
it or you've got mistaken ideas
then you can desire things like if you
think that that
celebrity and having a million facebook
followers or
instagram or whatever you want right is
like the sum
bonum of life uh because you believed
stupid people who said
stupid things like that well then you're
going to make dumb decisions your your
motivations
are going to be similarly flawed and
it's sort of like you know
garbage in garbage out in computer
programs right
and so there's there's going to be
differences between people and what they
desire
but hobbs does think that there are
certain
general dynamics
inclinations ways things work that we
can pick out
and so that that's what he does he says
there's some things that incline us
to war with each other that bring us
into conflict and he
he names a few of these competition of
riches honor command
or any other power inclines us to con
contention
enmity that's hatred and war because the
way of one competitor is the attaining
of his desire is to kill subdue supplant
or repel the other
particularly competition of praise
inclineth to a reverence of antiquity
you know he's got that as an example and
then he also talks about
um desire desiring
praise desiring honors in a military
context right
you can only really attain that if you
if you fight with somebody else
and you're probably not just going to
fight with the enemy you're probably
also going to contend with your
your fellow soldiers or generals or
whoever that happens to be and so hob
says you got to watch out for these
people those who are ambitious of
military command
are inclined to continue causes of war
and stir up trouble
and sedition right he's got this great
metaphor here about card games uh
they they have a hope to mend an ill
game by causing a new shuffle by
stirring things up right
and then there's all the things that
incline us to to piece
what what does hobbs think is conducive
to getting us to not go into conflict
with people
if we can avoid like you know
competition with them says
desire of ease desire to have leisure
desire not to be bothered
by other people just to do our work or
to have a vacation or whatever
sensual delight he says desire of
sensual delight to
enjoy the good things that we can eat or
drink
or you know sexual desires or laying in
the sun
that's all nice that's less likely to
get us into
into predicaments like that desire of
knowledge
and arts of peace incline people to obey
a common power
because this desire contains he says a
desire of leisure and consequently
protection from
desire from power other than their own
so if we follow that sort of stuff out
well you know when we structure it
properly we can get people to
want a a peaceful
conflict less or reduced conflict sort
of
situation and to obey some common ruler
or or sovereign he goes out and he talks
about praise and he says
desire of praise disposes a person to
laudable that means praise worthy
actions such as please them whose
judgment they
value so desire of fame does this
as well and that can motivate people
to do the right thing but it can also be
a little bit dangerous you know if they
think that they can
get the praise by stirring up trouble
they may do that
but he's got this really interesting
discussion of giving and receiving
benefits
you would think that if people are
giving benefits to other people
they're making their lives better that
would automatically
produce a more harmonious and
you know peace conducive situation and
hob
says no not necessarily
sometimes it can it can raise problems
so he says to have received from one
to whom we think ourselves equal greater
benefits than there is hope to requite
disposeth
to counterfeit love counterfeit love
fake love right really secret hatred and
puts a person into a state of a
desperate debtor
that in declining in the sight of his
creditor tacitly wishes him there
where he might never see him more
benefit benefits oblige hobb says
an obligation is thraldom an
unrequitable
obligation perpetual thraldom to be a
thrall means to be
somebody's servant or or slave
right so this is you know this is a
problem if you give
too much to somebody where they can't
return it and you're on the same level
they're not actually going to like you
they're going to hate you because of it
but they're going to pretend to like you
so he goes on to have received benefits
from one who we acknowledge for superior
above us inclines us to love
because the obligation is no new
depression and cheerful acceptation
which we call gratitude
is an honor done to the obliger as is
taken generally for retribution
so that's interesting if the person's on
the same level as us and they do
something really good for us we feel
like they're actually
putting us down but if they're already
above
us and they do something good for us
we're like i'm cool with that as a
matter of fact i'm gonna give you praise
and honor
for being so good to me right and so we
have a different situation there he
he also says uh to receive benefits
though from an equal or inferior
if there is hope of requiting it
disposes to love for in the intention of
the receiver the obligation is of
aid and service mutual so you know you
can have what he calls an emulation
between it this friend gives some
something to their friend and the other
friend then gives something back and
they maybe add a little bit on to it and
then this person
you know competes with them a bit in
trying to uh
do more and this is good this actually
works out quite well this conduces to
peace
because they they are you know
developing a kind of
mutual and reciprocal love for each
other because they
can respond in kind isn't that an
interesting dynamic that he talks about
he also talks about like hurting people
to have done more hurt to a person
than he can or is willing to expiate and
kleineth the doer the person who does
the thing to hate the sufferer because
they have to expect revenge or
forgiveness
both of which are as he says hateful
so that's that's quite interesting isn't
it
um he also talks quite a bit about the
valuation of
oneself in relation to other people
and he tells us that vainglorious people
uh those without being conscious to
themselves of great sufficiency
delight in supposing themselves gallant
and are inclined
to ostentation but not to attempt right
because they
they don't want to have their
insufficiency revealed but those who
estimate their sufficiency by the
flattery of other people or the fortune
of precedent action
will do stupid things they will you know
and this is coming from vainglory
thinking that you're better than you are
so you know prime example of this
somebody who you know
they invest in the stock market they
don't really know what they're doing
and they win big and they're like oh man
i'm the king i'm on top of everything
give me your money
they're going to make stupid decisions
and then you know
sooner or later things are going to fall
apart right
he also talks about people that have a
strong opinion of their own wisdom and
matter of government are disposed to
ambition without public employment and
counsel or magistry
the honor of their wisdom is lost
eloquent speakers are inclined to
ambition
people who think that they are good at
something
want to get in there and get some sort
of role now he's talking about you know
in a civil
society sort of thing we could think
about business settings
sports settings academic settings i'm
really good at aristotle there should be
a chair for me
right all that sort of stuff people get
ambitious
and ambitioned it really depends on
how it's used it could conduce to war it
could conduce to peace
he also uses this word uh possibility
and he says it disposes people to ear
resolution what are we talking about
there
you know a lack of trust within oneself
you know
people who suffer from imposter syndrome
might be subject to what hobbes
is calling it here and he says that
this ear resolution means losing
occasions and the fittest opportunities
of action if they've been in
deliberation until the time of action
approach
if it not be manifest what is best to be
done the difference of motives the one
way or the other are not great
and so the way to resolve them is to
lose to to
not to resolve them is to lose the
occasion by weighing of trifles
which is this this disposition of
anonymity right and so you know
how we value ourself determines what
we're going to do
he also devotes a good bit of discussion
to ignorance or
knowledge of two important things one of
which is this general term of causes how
things actually
work what's related to what and then the
signification
of words and he tells us that if we
don't really understand
the signification of words we're going
to mix up our evaluations of action so
we'll
you know this may not be something that
you can relate to but if you actually
know
the background when the senators of rome
killed kalatine
uh you know and when they killed caesar
one of those cases for hobbes
presumably was was good and one of those
was was bad
um it's still a killing how do you
distinguish between it well you have to
understand
the signification of the other words
right
and in a lot of cases we don't
understand the causes of things whether
it be natural phenomena
or our own emotions or why people do
things
and if we don't understand these things
like it says ignorant
ignorance of the causes and original
constitution of right equity law and
justice
disposes a person to make custom an
example the rule of their actions right
and so they become
conservative in not a particularly
political
sense but in the sense of like just
saying well we can't really reason our
way to these these things
ignorance of remote causes disposes
people to attribute
all events to the causes immediate and
instrumental because these are the
causes they perceive
right ignorance of natural causes
disposes a person to credulity to
believing in
things that they they shouldn't and then
there's things that dispose us
to try to figure out causes he talks
about anxiety
for the future time disposes people to
inquire into the causes of things
because we want to know how things work
curiosity or love of the knowledge of
causes draws a person from consideration
of effect
to seek the cause and again from the
cause of the of that cause until
by necessity they come to the the cause
that
that started things and and hobbes
thinks this is you know
quite good um we we should cultivate
our knowledge of causes and
signification of
words as much as we can but we're always
limited and
the ignorance of these things will
dispose people to
buy into to believe and then to act upon
right we have motives and desires act
upon and feel
certain ways so you know all of this
is sort of a rudimentary moral
psychology it goes with the things
that he said a little bit earlier in the
work about the
nature of the different passions and
endeavor and appetite and
aversion and all that it also fits in
with
the stuff in the chapter just before it
about how we value
people and this allows us to make sense
out of our social world
you